élever des animaux produire ses propres
fourrages à la ferme ça demande beaucoup
de travail surtout quand on est seul
voilà pourquoi le maillage agricole qui
jumelle un propriétaire avec une relève
potentielle est une solution
intéressante mais comme vous allez le
voir dans ce portrait est très intimiste
et plein de candeur les défis d'un tel
parcours sont parfois et soupçonnés
mon entreprise je veux qu'elle soit
vivable elle est viable l'économiquement
soit il y a pas de problème mais qu'elle
soit vivable
qui pour ça il faut que ma blonde soit
heureuse il faut que je sois heureux
[Musique]
je suis capable d'aller souper puis
capable d'arriver à l'heure à un repas
de famille
puis un moment donné tu as beau dire
dans ta tête il faut que je prenne des
vacances c'est important tu es pas
capable
tu arrives juste plus à dire j'y vais
[Musique]
je m'appelle Alexandre je suis
copropriétaire de l'entreprise ferme
l'agit bien ici à Saint-Mathieu j'habite
ce village là depuis toujours
ma ferme est une entreprise ovine de
première génération
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 1200 1300
têtes c'est
550 brebis qui agnelle à l'année ça fait
2200 2400 agneaux qui viennent au monde
la ferme produit tous ces fourrages et
tous ces grains c'est
455 heures en culture donc c'est
énormément de travail c'est très
exigeant
j'avais besoin absolument
d'améliorer ma qualité de vie c'est sûr
que dans les options on pense à la
relève familiale dans mon cas j'ai 4
enfants et 4 enfants qui ont d'autres
intérêts et c'est très très bien comme
ça
donc c'est là que je me suis dit ça me
prend une association mais c'est pas
comme vendre son entreprise parce que je
dois travailler avec cette personne là
pour les 20 prochaines années
plus on vaccine Des Agnelles quand tu
fais ça tout seul tu te retrouves avec
une aiguille plantée dans le doigt
et voilà celle qui s'était blessée et là
c'est encore de l'enflure un peu je
m'appelle David Garion copropriétaire de
la ferme la bitibienne avec Alexandre je
déménagé dans la maison voisine de la
ferme il y a 9 mois avec ma famille ma
conjointe mes trois enfants
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé à travailler sur des
fermetures en 2006
jusqu'à 2021 jusqu'à ce que j'arrive ici
dans l'agneau
[Applaudissements]
c'est une grosse toile que moi
le secteur ovin ça m'a surpris moi-même
parce que j'avais juste un objectif les
vaches laitières les vaches laitières
[Musique]
ma façon de voir les choses est-ce que
je m'achète une ferme toute seule
j'avais peur de la solitude un peu puis
c'est toujours travailler toute terre
tout le temps tout le temps je vais
regarder pour une ferme laitière mais
avec un partenaire puis l'artère me
présentait il me dit ah un partenaire
j'en aurai un mais ça serait dans le vin
là j'étais pas sûr de ce qui m'a envoyé
là
je m'appelle Jean-Philippe Mainville je
suis agent de mariage pour l'artère au
Bas Saint-Laurent l'artère on a un
service de jumelage en propriétaire
d'actifs agricoles ou d'entreprises
agricoles puis de relève qui veulent
s'établir en agriculture dans le fond
c'est une agence de rencontre agricole
sa vie à mettre en relation des cédants
comme moi un propriétaire d'entreprise
agricoles qui n'ont pas de relais et des
aspirants agriculteurs comme David par
exemple qui souhaite devenir producteur
mais qui n'ont pas de faire
ce qui est le plus me chercher dans ce
travail-là c'est quand il y a un
propriétaire qui voulait démanteler son
entreprise qui croyait pas qu'il y avait
de possibilité de trouver une relève
puis qu'on trouve une relève puis que ça
marche et que on a contribué à préserver
une entreprise sur le territoire
[Musique]
bénéficier aux communautés pour les
garder dynamiques
[Musique]
on est en train de piler de la paille là
ça fait 2800 balles en deux jours et
puis je dois les derniers à faire ça
cette pratique de un peu gelée de piler
la paille sur le fini
je vous cacherai pas que avant de
choisir les moutons j'ai choisi
l'entrepreneur
j'ai vu un gars qui était organisé qui
avait un but qui aimait les rendements
puis ça ça me beaucoup parler
une des lignes directrices que guider le
développement de l'entreprise depuis le
début c'est l'efficacité du travail ici
j'ai développé des façons de faire pour
éviter 200 poids là pour éviter 200 pas
là pour que ça aille plus vite ça veut
dire que j'ai développé une espèce de
maladie il faut tout aille vite faut que
tout soit bien fait rapidement et ça ça
implique que le gars qui arrive avec moi
il faut qu'il suivent tout seul ce que
j'ai pris 22 ans à développer il faut
qu'il embarque dans ça et puis le David
arrive il doit intégrer tout ça assez
rapidement puis si embarque pas des fois
ça me fait signe des fois c'est c'est
dur à c'est long c'est ça la faire tout
prend du temps
on voit les envoyer tout de suite avec
le groupe le prochain groupe apaisé puis
ceux qui sont marqués mais ils sont déjà
pesés au début mon partenaire disait tu
vas apprendre ça vite c'est bon d'un
vache tu vas prendre ça vite là je
centaine de pressions je suis posé quand
moi je suppose que ça puis waouh ça
rentre pas aussi vite que je pensais
[Musique]
ce qui est une évidence pour moi ne
l'est pas pour David et puis là ça
demande un travail sur moi-même
d'accepter de répéter mais de répéter
sans être trop tendance sans être trop
gosse j'aime bien utiliser le terme
gossant parce que c'est comme ça que je
me sens souvent je sens que je suis
gossant avec David
la pression qu'on se donne aussi de
vouloir performer dans ça de vouloir que
le match en tout peu plus moins soit
parfait ça se pouvait pas non mais c'est
sûr qu'il y a toute une question de
tempérament il y a des bouts on se
rejoint énormément donc moi je pense
qu'on a bien plus de points de rencontre
on a beaucoup de points de rencontre
j'ai confiance
là ce qu'il faut se préoccuper c'est de
maintenir une bonne relation d'essayer
d'évacuer là les frustrations qu'on peut
avoir puis ça je pense que ça va nous
prendre un peu d'aide pour passer à
travers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de chacun puisqu'on va avoir chacun
notre secteur
je suis Anthony Rodrigue conseillère au
créa du bassin Laurent c'est à dire
centre régional d'établissement en
agriculture bassin-laurent depuis
1996 la mission du créa c'est toute la
compagnement comme expert en gestion du
processus de transfert donc on accouche
de projets de transfert on est comme des
sages-femmes par rapport au transfert
c'est vraiment un beau métier
toi tu veux bien performer puis
Alexandre il y a des attentes aussi il
faut revenir
à la base l'objectif en fait c'est de
permettre que les vrais affaires se
disent si on veut que l'entreprise soit
en santé mais on veut que l'équipe
nouvellement constituée demeure en santé
réglons à mesure accumulés
on dirait que les gens voient moins la
pertinence de faire ça mais quand on est
dans un processus de changement dans un
processus de transition c'est encore
plus important parce que les roses
changent c'est des responsabilités
changent donc c'est important d'en
parler
[Musique]
vous êtes en train de prendre racine
pour tout le monde
[Musique]
plus pour David
la production en ville c'est quand même
portée parce que j'ai je me dis j'ai pas
de référence
j'ai pas de référence en production en
ville
il disait oh ça va me prendre un arbre
peut-être deux quelque chose comme ça
moi je me disais ça va prendre deux mois
là il va s'habituer au Piton il va
s'amuser au mouton
les séances avec Antony nous permettent
de prendre le temps de s'asseoir et de
discuter d'organisation du travail de
bien-être personnel de satisfaction il
faut que David ne soit pas déçu ce
second là doit être heureux ici j'ai pas
le choix d'avoir un gars heureux avec
moi
[Musique]
c'est comme un psychologue un peu pour
nous là fait sortir les émotions à
mettre des mots sur certaines émotions
quand on a fini de parler avec antonyme
il me semble que on est moins pesait
dans ce que tu aimes Alexandre
l'entreprise tu fais le pari que elle va
pouvoir continuer d'évoluer avec un
partenaire comme comme David en fait moi
j'ai une conviction c'est que mon
entreprise elle aurait pas continuer
d'évoluer
que
je suis fatigué j'ai été fatigué je le
suis encore
limite etc
pour le temps pour l'été que j'ai passé
là avec Alexandre son état d'esprit moi
j'ai vu grosse différence avec les
dépensé me faites plein de petites
choses qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire avant
qui a fait toute la différence
[Musique]
des heures de repas d'envisager des
sorties parce que David va terminer la
job David va la faire au complet c'est
énorme comme toi que ça peut enlever
puis je pense que ça va aller de mieux
en mieux parce que David est en train de
s'habituer à l'ensemble des tâches qu'il
y a quand le mouton va parler comme le
vache me parlait ça va ça va un aller
[Musique]